here are five reasons why london's
long-awaited 18.9 billion pound
crossworld project will change the
capital one quicker journeys an
additional 1.5 million people will be
within a 45-minute commuting distance
from the capital's major commercial and
business centres the west end the city
and canary wharf
a journey from liverpool street to
village will be halved to 15 minutes
while the trip between farringdon and
canary wharf which currently takes 24
minutes will take just 10. 2.
regeneration up until now access to
central london from essex and berkshire
as well as many london suburbs has been
long and arduous often requiring a
combination of trains tubes and buses
this has made them unattractive places
to live for commuters the elizabeth line
will likely bring investment to london
suburbs and local towns
three
less congestion prior to covid the
underground was notoriously busy during
peak hours
with the elizabeth line london's trains
are likely to become notably less
congested
capacity will be greater than all the
other lions with nine carriage
state-of-the-art trains at 200 metres
long accommodating up to 1 500
passengers each
the northern line by comparison has a
per train capacity of just 800. four
accessibility given london's population
over 65 is expected to be 62 higher by
2040 the need for accessible stations is
only going to grow all elizabeth line
stations have step free access from
street level to platform this is a game
changer before crosswell for example a
step-free journey between paddington and
tottenham court road the distance of two
miles meant traveling on two buses for
25 minutes on the elizabeth line it
takes just five
five
faster heathrow access
speedy travel to the uk's largest
airport is currently expensive and or
time consuming a same-day ticket on the
heathrow express will set you back 25
pounds and take 15 minutes while the
three pounds 50 off peak tube ticket
from paddington will take at least 48
minutes
in comparison the elizabeth line would
take just 30 minutes far more convenient
for those quick weekend getaways or last
minute work trips